okay today I'm going to talk to you
about acceleration I'm also going to
show you how to use this particular
equation and how it relates to real life
situations involving acceleration so
what does acceleration actually mean all
acceleration means is a change in
velocity remember velocity is just how
fast some things go in so if something
starts off slow and then gets faster
increases velocity is accelerating but
if it starts off faster then slows down
it is decelerating so let's see how this
equation here relates to a real-life
example and I'm going to do it a
real-life example involving a car so
let's say here is my car right here
we're going to see how we're going to
calculate the acceleration from this car
going from Stood Still
to moving at a speed of 50 meters per
second okay so the first thing that
we're going to think about is our
starting point now let's say this car is
stationary is still if it's stationary
it was going to have a speed of 0 meters
per second now how does this relate to
this equation here now this letter here
u that is our initial velocity so that's
how fast this is moving to begin with so
we could see to begin with this is going
to travel in at 0
we'll put the numbers in in a minute now
let's say this car has sped up to a
speed of 50 meters per second so we
could see this V here that is our final
velocity of 50 meters per second so in a
second when we put the numbers in we can
start to see where they go
but to calculate acceleration we need to
know how long has this change in
velocity occurred over so let's say it's
taken us 10 seconds to go from
stationary 250 meters per second now
this T here simply stands for time so
let's try and put these numbers in
now remember our final velocity was 50
initial velocity was zero but so I did
in the wrong color with zero and our
time taken was 10 seconds so 50 take
away zero is just 50 and 50 divided by
10 because it took 10 seconds is 5 and
that gives us our a and obviously our a
stands for acceleration now the units
for acceleration is meters per second
squared now this shows acceleration but
can we also do this to show deceleration
let's imagine the same car now joins are
getting worse at this car let's say this
car now instead of speeding up it slows
down from let's say here it's now
traveling at 50 meters per second so at
the beginning of this one so this is a
different question this time we've got
this car that starts off traveling at 50
or 50 meters per second and then it
slams on the brakes and slows down to
being completely stationary so let's say
this time it takes five seconds to do
that because we're slamming on the
brakes let's see how this changes our
calculation so our final velocity this
time is going to be zero because we've
we've come to a halt it's not moving
it's traveling at speed of zero meters
per second our initial velocity we
started off this car was traveling at 50
meters per second and then we're going
to divide that answer by how long it
took the car to break which is five
okay now be careful with this bit here
we can see this zero take away 50 so on
top we're gonna have minus 50 and on the
bottom we're just gonna have five
because it's taken five seconds for it
to slow down so minus 50 divided by 5
gives us our acceleration which is 10
meters per second squared okay minus 10
meters per second squared now we can
notice if we have a minus velocity of a
minus acceleration like this it shows us
that our object has slowed down so
that's how all of these different parts
of the equation relate to real life
situations and remember if we've got a
negative number negative acceleration it
shows that our object has slowed down
thank you